[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
ma chance
mais je vous raconte tout vous savez
comment c'est là que j'ai commencé la
réunion de ce matin ils étaient là
d'ailleurs est ce que j'ai dit ce matin
j'ai dit j'ai des grands motifs de
satisfaction sur l'émission d'hier est
mon plus grand motif de satisfaction
c'est cédric 6 heures merci beaucoup
orange et blu ray rappelez vous je vais
y aller au bout cette impression à voter
die meisten ce soir on a eu une très
belle image pour ceux qui aiment les
animaux vous verrez alors série hier
soir je vous ai remis un laurier pour un
moment extraordinaire qu'on a vue d'en
voir un poste vendredi
tout le monde m'en a parlé j'ai reçu pas
moins de trois sms alors à la demande
générale on va revoir le moment où notre
ami mills m me rappeler cet intervenant
qui a couché avec sa prof vous annonce
qu'il est un grand séducteur
et comme vous avez du mal à cacher vos
émotions leurs devoirs pourquoi hier
vous avez remporté le laurier du gars
qui a du mal à cacher qu'il n'est pas
convaincu par ce qu'on lui raconte on
s'en lasse pas
on est jeune on aime bien séduire et ça
c'est un mec pour défaut je suis un con
séducteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
gt non mais oh ça mais je crois qu'elle
aurait dû rejeter mission l'a 9 heures
du matin est concentrée à 2 heures du
matin voilà je gâche sur la vie quoi la
demande est longue alors cyril c'est
vrai que ça fait presque un mois déjà
que j'ai le plaisir d'être avec vous
tous les soirs
oui c'est vrai qu'un mode chronique avec
vous ça équivaut à 44 ans de chroniques
dans télématin ça c'est vrai c'est
incroyable et lors de ma chronique de
jeudi j'ai eu la tristesse de constater
que certaines personnes tenté de saboter
mon travail non666 ma chronique dérange
bah ouais sur ma chronique dérange et
ces personnes travaillent à la chaîne
que vous dirigez alors attention à ce
que tu fais de ma dernière ma dernière
alors le suspect numéro un pour moi
c'est cette personne c'est fini en
quatrième où c'est le président de la
chaîne bâtiment spécial du camouflage et
sosie vocal de claude alexis je vous
explique souvent nous pendant l'émission
la chaîne passe maintenant bandeau pour
annoncer le programme du sommet est
comme ça faut arrêter ça d'ailleurs
les bandeaux comme ça on est en train de
faire un truc hyper important et atteint
bandeau qui arrive ce soir au tableau on
est très content de voir au tableau mais
si c'est pour avoir un bandeau qui fait
que tout l'écran je veux dire ça va
chier des bulles qu'à regarder ce qui va
se passer qui s'est passé alors seconde
repassé au moment pile où je faisais une
claque visuelle
non mais ce qui fait que personne n'a
compris pourquoi nous en rigolant
plateau et il y avait une chance sur
cinq minutes que ça tombe pile à ce
moment là mais évidemment c'est arrivé
c'est une séquence là qui changent pas
j'ai pas de chance mais qu'allez vous
racontiez que vous aviez rêvé de cyril
hanouna et vous allez voir donc pourquoi
j'ai décidé de remettre assez vite le
laurier de la chaîne qui a décidé de
honteusement saboté une chronique
on sait tous que vous avez déjà rêvé de
monde ici comme si j'allais chercher
pendant tout le même et je n'ai pas
trouvé
[Applaudissements]
donc j'ai voulu zoomer sur votre visage
qui se décompose quand vous faites vache
et par christine kelly et voilà ce qui
est apparu à l'antenne pile à l'endroit
où vous avez votre visage c'est
magnifique
quelle bande normal
personne n'a compris le manoir
arrétez arrétez arrétez va se soumettre
des passes longues soit on adore mais
c'est en plus et bernard de la
villardière qui produisent
ça fait donc ça va durer longtemps
possible sa cible et verifone et où
s'élabore en réunion ils étaient un peu
toi les juifs mi raisin je sais les
statuts moi et c'était comme moi tu
voyais et voient ils ont voulu me faire
ch matin comme on dit toi tu as fait
détoner là ce soir francs capitaux
il vient pour le prime de kenji non on
me dit qu'il est en vacances de février
ont lembras à lembras franck merci on
sera là pour le prg m de chez gaffe le
troisième tour de ski très rose toujours
la qualité accidents arrivent en
confiance et labit mais voilà alors on
va tenter une nouvelle fois dont enfin
revoir votre tête au moment que si mme
kelly expliqué cherche bozzi en espérant
que cette fois la chaîne lance pour la
pub je vais chercher pour tout l'est
mais je n'ai pas trouvé
[Musique]
mais j'arrête craquelage comprend on est
potes depuis des années là mais je sais
que tu m'en veux ton pas du tout pas du
tout sinon moi je le vois tu vas
t'enfoncer
on va arrêter on va parler maintenant
d'autres choses si vous tapez d'arca sur
internet vous êtes sûr de ne pas tomber
sur carl rousseau apathique carole
rousseau si elle fait partie est ce qu'à
fait pas partie du top 2 de nos
animatrices préférées
hier soir j'en étais sûr voilà alors bon
car le ruisseau c'est une très bonne
animatrice mais on peut pas dire qu'on
imagine faire des soirées qui se termine
en voir la chenille à 7 heures du matin
c'est pas le style quoi je pense pas
emma figurez vous qu'on sait tous
trompés bah on sait tous trompés
ah oui vous allez voir après l'avoir vu
dans les enfants de la télé je suis
obligé dû décerner le laurier de la meuf
qui a toujours été coincé et qui d'un
coup se lâche complètement
[Musique]
vous conduisait la voiture qui auront
écouté j'ai adoré ça j'ai toujours été
fourré dans des voitures et moi ça
[Applaudissements]
j'avais comme d'ailleurs les motos macri
laurent ofii et valérie bénaïm alors on
va les réviser il m'a posé une question
de talent heures je le dis toujours aux
téléspectateurs ça fait depuis trois
jours qu'elle m'appelle muté joue elle a
été invitée dans les enfants de la télé
est me demande mon autorisation
oui mon patron c'est oui on va y aller
aux enfants de la télé et s'ils veulent
vous gardez vous pouvez rester d'accord
voilà voilà mesdames c'est clair c'est
net book faites vous plaisir
voilà merci à d'autres demandes 1 il y
en a quatre habiter dans motus voilà la
seule chose le le maître mot voilà comme
ça vous le savez allez-y et voilà et si
on a qui peuvent râler dans fort boyard
y rester et ben voilà des mots clés
seraient nécessaires pékin express les
faire pékin express rive allégé tout de
suite des maris est-ce que vous souvenez
de danièle gilbert
bien sûr c'était là valérie bègue il
adore et daniel d'ailleurs je conseille
de skate elle a perdu son mari
dernièrement et je fais un gros bisou
voilà d'ailleurs c'était là valérie
benaïm les indices mais sans la
moustache monsieur efforts pour arrêter
les marranes sur la mousse à bonal on
arrête avec ce pays ni gêne ni
d'irréprochable va pas savoir vachement
et benayoun et je vous lis ça vous va à
merveille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces pannes stage mousser un duvet d'oie
après les gens vont croire mais non pas
parce qu'on fait attention pas de
moustache
non mais c'est pas la peine de regarder
en tout cas pas à l'oeil nu
alors venez gilbert était l'invité d'une
autre légende de la télé sur idf1 jacky
jacky alors demandez pas pourquoi mais
l'émission de jacques qui s'appelle
jacky love plus propre on sait pas
pourquoi et comme jacky c'est un mec
moderne ça s'appelle le jlp p ah ouais
mais bon à chaque on sait que le 1 de
idf1 c'est pour le nombre de
téléspectateurs mais c'est sûr que ce
téléspectateur c'est pas daniel gilbert
parce que voici le laurier de l'invité
qui sait même pas dans quelle émission
aller
[Musique]
j'ai une envie d'aller vers les gens
c'est à dire d'en mener les missions
vous et moi en province
voilà c'est un peu comme le jlp jacky la
plus propre que là où tu es en ce moment
c'est la boucherie juhel peu mieux
alors est ce que vous connaissez le
magazine de la santé
bien sûr à 100 que le rêve de présenter
10 me mohamed j'en suis sûr avec j'adore
marina car donc aussi adore
effectivement alors franchement dans
cette émission il parle toujours de
sujets sains pas alzheimer maladies
mentales ou encore complexe de la vulve
mais hier ils ont parlé de quelqu'un
qu'on connaît bien
voici le laurier des missions médicales
qui parle d'un chroniqueur de tpm paix
non
et on termine ce journal avec l' affaire
qui secoue les pays bas en ce moment un
médecin exerçant dans une clinique de
fertilité à rotterdam est soupçonné
d'être le père biologique de son enfant
tu es bien on a retrouvé ce fameux papa
de deux cents enfants
regardez-moi ça
[Applaudissements]
d'écouter ce sont les bêtises son
abitibi
samedi soir c'était l'avant dernière
d'une de mes sessions de préfet
émissions préférées les années bonheur
aux jurés c'était magnifique
alors bientôt drh ne pas faire ces
gentils ou cyril quand tu actes j'adore
quand il fait ça bientôt delphine
ernotte va pouvoir déboucher le
champagne quand elle se sera débarrassé
dans des soldats qui lui fait de
l'audience
elle n'aime pas ça bref dans les années
bonheur patrick sébastien est accompagné
par le grand fabien lecoeuvre l'ennemi
juré de bernard montiel
ah ouais c'est vrai il se bat avant
d'aller à l'arrière pour être les
premiers aux enterrements les deux là
ces hommes se détestent fois avec strand
la photo il faisait entre membres à ce
qu'est mon pote pas bien grosse photo à
laver la photosphère le connaissais pas
il a dit qu on se pâme a adoré faire un
coup contre fabien lecoeuvre et bernard
montiel ça serait qui sera le meilleur
ami des stars ça serait pas mal
fabien lecoeuvre dans les années bonheur
il souffre ce qui laissa il existe et il
essaie d'apporter des infos il se bat
mais ça marche pas parce que patrick y
fait son truc il écoute même pas alors
je remets à fabien lecoeuvre le laurier
du gars qui essaient d'en placer une
mais tout le monde s'en fout
[Musique]
il a été numéro 1 au billboard a osé aux
usa le 27 juillet 1987 aux états unis
tête et premier aux états unis toi c'est
les meilleures ventes de l'année
dernière aussi avec la démo évidemment
voilà c'est vital vous allez pouvoir
temps ci dessous vous connaissez que sa
taille c'est monsieur aux liens que ça
s'appelle deux ans de carrière alors
qu'est-ce que sa carte dans les pièces
quand même c'est ce qu'on appelle à la
deep house dre carton dans le monde
entier en ce moment il ya deux titres
toi
[Applaudissements]
au regard des femmes et le coeur va
encore se battre pour parler et quand il
va placer une info en dans steam qui
connaît par coeur la carrière de
salvatore adamo
ça va être un drame soixante ans de
carrière oui presque 50 cd 105 ans je
suis fan de bowie poignet et d'alto et
puis lui 10 59 et autre fait sans effet
[Rires]
la photo fabien aubat l'as rome est
hélas un peu derrière au sac il faut la
déception alors vous savez toujours je
voue un véritable culte alors on met ce
qu il présente deux des émissions les
plus modernes de la télé aux actuels des
chiffres et des lettres et météo à la
carte et ouais ça cartonne météo la
caresse ou presque un million par jour
d'une émission sur la météo on n'y
croyait pas du tout au départ et sa
carte et puis voilà toutes les missions
il y fait brut papoul à la fin tu sais
croire le vote à temps la dame n'est pas
finalement il fait beau principe c'est
le concept est simple c'est sur france 3
il présente cette émission avec marine
vignes
ouais marine vie alors autant mon des
chiffres des lettres romejko bertrand
renard c'est les chevaliers du fiel
bref c'est des blacks tout en ôtant
métaux à la carte c'est aussi tendue
qu'à l'époque de christophe dechavanne
et valérie benaïm sur tf1 c'est très
tendu vous allez voir comment laurent
romejko un coup de pression à marine
vignes en fait d'un veto à la carte ya
de l'orage dans l'air
il a travaillé deux ans avec anne
roumanoff c'est le laurier c'est donc le
laurier du duo d'animateurs il ne peut
plus se blairer
[Musique]
c'est d'actualité en et a reçu son c'est
dans les vosges avec une photo de
bertrand bertrand n'a pas oublié la
saint valentin
lui oui effectivement non je crains pas
pour moulant gillepsie soir pour la
saint valentin on travaille ensemble
oui bien sûr c'est bien des gens avec un
autre nom fait montre exactement si on
reconnaîtra merci
jo voilà j'ai pris doigts d'une main
alors il faut rendre l'antenne n'est pas
bien voilà il ya eu a franchement
grossier météo à lattaquié donc mais
c'est sympa nous avons pas d inviter
tient pour savoir un petit peu le
symbole d'affaires annuel va partir en
enquête ils vont passer à table alors je
voudrais maintenant parler du game of
frog français les mystères de la feria
ta chronique dur de plus en plus
longtemps
je m'adapte ya deux semaines deux
minutes de plus je ne supportais pas ça
va très vite ça va alors il bosse bien
plus de choses de ouf dans les mystères
de l'amour que dans game of thrones bien
des enlèvements
laly qui parlait qu'un fantôme josé qui
vit en troubles et surtout des dialogues
extraordinaire de celui qu'on admire
tous
jean luc ruch que j'adore vraiment alors
il est tellement fort jean luc qui écrit
tout mais il fait beaucoup de choses
donc des fois y'a pas trop le temps
d'écrire et dialogue
alors il a une super technique il fait
répéter aux comédiens plusieurs fois la
même chose parce c'est incroyable alors
je lui décerne le laurier du gars qui
prend une blinde en droit d'auteur sens
fériés
je suis assez c'est pas magnola je suis
un de ses amis mais
j'ai ramassé son téléphone devant chez
moi mais c'est quoi cette histoire qui
est patrice attendez vous êtes qui vous
d'abord papa john greyson comme je vous
dis j'ai ramassé téléphone ces personnes
vous répond il faut prévenir manuel
atteste ce même circuit
j'ai aucune nouvelle je sais pas où les
tue comme je vous dis je en a ramassé un
téléphone par terre devant chez moi et
alors dans le même épisode regarder
franck des to be free qu'explique qui a
vu un type ou devant un portail dans sa
bagnole curé
issia
le type qui attendait devant le portail
ce matin dans sa bagnole
comment ça le type 4
portez à notre article ce matin qui
attendait devant le portail dans sa
bagnole et pourquoi tu m'a rien dit mais
moi je pensais juste que c'est un type
qui attendaient devant le temps
[Applaudissements]
à l'été dernier extrait donc ça y est on
est est ce que vous aimez les animaux ça
va voilà bien dans les nombreux chiens
peaux d'animaux
j'en ai d'ailleurs plein là mais il
paraît pas alors dans l'émission de mon
ami daphné bürki cela que j'ai découvert
une femme qui adore les animaux
une femme cadre les animaux c'est une
certaine muriel bec avec voilà ça
s'invente pas elle a un lynx qu'elle
aime beaucoup qu'elle aime trop qu'elle
aime profondément
voici pour finir le laurier de la meuf
qui a la tête dans le cul non
je ressens les fesses d'enfer exemple
rien
qu'est-ce que faire
je fais mais c'est un pari que ça fait
du bien il paraît que l'animal est
revigoré j'étais crevé le rebond à
l'inversé
[Applaudissements]